[Música]
las plantas son uno de los organismos
más importantes de nuestro planeta
fijan el dióxido de carbono nos dan el
oxígeno que respiramos y además de
alimentos nos dan productos que son
utilizados en diferentes industrias como
la textil la farmacéutica y la
alimentaria
tienen un papel primordial en la cadena
alimenticia por lo que tienen un alto
valor ecológico son refugio de
microorganismos de insectos benéficos y
de otros animales funcionan como filtro
de la contaminación ambiental regulan la
humedad la temperatura estabilizan el
clima y de hecho reducen el
calentamiento global
de la existencia de las plantas dependen
casi todos los organismos incluso el
propio planeta
pero hoy estoy aquí no para hablar sobre
la ciencia de las plantas
por más de 30 años he dedicado las
investigaciones científicas encaminadas
a la propagación conservación
mejoramiento genético y al estudio de
los compuestos bioactivos de las plantas
en este tiempo con diferentes grupos de
investigación
hemos establecido sistemas de
propagación de plantas de interés
agrícola forestal ornamental y medicinal
pero sobre todo de aquellas que están en
peligro de extinción como las orquídeas
además hemos identificado compuestos de
interés con propiedades antimicrobianas
antioxidantes antiinflamatorias algunos
de ellos con gran potencial de ser
probados en tratamiento del tratamiento
de algunos tipos de cáncer diabetes
mellitus e hipertensión pero no estoy
aquí para hablar más sobre la ciencia de
las plantas
en diferentes foros de ciencias talleres
congresos en las aulas dando clases con
mis estudiantes en el laboratorio con
los tesistas pero también en mi vida
cotidiana en reuniones de amigos y de
familia generalmente me han hecho me
hacen dos preguntas estás relacionadas
con la ciencia de las plantas la primera
de ellas es muy fácil de contestar de
hecho se responde por sí misma con lo
anteriormente expuesto esta es porque
trabajo con plantas
la necesidad de propagar las de
conservarlas de hacer mejoramiento
genético y de estudiar sus compuestos
activos justifica realmente su estudio
sin embargo la segunda pregunta
generalmente me es difícil contestar la
siempre divagó mucho para hacerlo
por el momento no la digo porque antes
quiero comentarles que además de ser un
científico estudioso de las plantas
me declaro un fanático admirador y
cultivador de ellas
casi también por 30 años he llegado a
tener una colección de cientos de
especies de ellas de bromelias
insectívoras helechos crasuláceas tan
conocidas como suculentas como las que
verías o las siempre vivas pero
mayormente de orquídeas
cuando digo que las cultivo es que les
doy el tiempo necesario para podar las
para limpiarlas para regarlas para
fertilizar las
para evitar que se enfermen y tenerlas
en el mejor de los cultivos
como me doy cuenta si tengo un éxito en
el cultivo de mis plantas pues es la
recompensa que ellas dan de dar cantidad
y hermosas flores y ver su óptimo
crecimiento
el cultivo de las plantas no es por mi
experiencia científica simplemente esto
viene de mucho tiempo atrás mucho antes
de ser científico y es por eso que hoy
estoy aquí no para hablar sobre la
ciencia de las plantas
ya que todo gira alrededor de esta
segunda pregunta que ahora la digo cómo
y cuándo nació en mí el interés por
estudiar por trabajar por cultivar
plantas
para poder contestarla necesito decirles
que afortunadamente fui un niño de 4
años que tenía la manera de jugar en el
jardín de la casa de mis padres con mis
hermanos con amigos con primos
en este lugar muy cercano estaba la casa
de los abuelos con un jardín mucho más
grande y con mucho más plantas
plantas que la abuela cultivaba le
gustaban las rosas las azucenas
cultivaban zanahorias cilantro rábanos
aromáticas como la hierbabuena la ruda y
la albahaca
y entre los frutales había membrillos
ciruelas mangos aguacates naranjas y
limas y a veces había piñas
verdaderamente como dicen recordar es
vivir
pero en que estaba en la segunda
pregunta como ven es difícil para mí
responderla pero continuando diría que a
esta edad además de jugar teníamos que
hacer actividades en casa y una de ellas
y la que más me gustaba era precisamente
regar las plantas una tarea fácil
cambiar la manguera de un tiesto a otro
o regar las macetas y las jardineras de
la abuela
con esta actividad aprendí la necesidad
del agua por las plantas que requerían
nutrientes al fertilizar las y abonar
las que era importante podar las para
que tuvieran más follaje o más ramas y
así más flores y más frutos
y también saber cómo cuidarlas para que
no se enfermaron
y obviamente lo más rico de esta época y
esta temporada era cosechar los ricos
frutos y saborear los y también admirar
y ver oler las flores de la abuela
quizás al pasar el tiempo sin darme
cuenta en los estudios básicos de
primaria
ya me sabía nombres científicos de casi
todas estas plantas persea americana del
aguacate de buscar hato de la zanahoria
qué elementos esenciales serán y
nutrición de la planta y su función como
el nitrógeno el fósforo y el potasio y
también aprendí que las plantas no
solamente se reproducían por semilla
como ese experimento que hacemos en
primaria de sembrar la semilla de frijol
en un algodón húmedo y ver el proceso de
la germinación y el desarrollo de la
planta no en casa hacíamos otros
sistemas de propagación la asexual
propaga vamos de segmentos de tallo las
estacas de esquejes con hojas y de
hijuelos y de esa manera propaga vamos
las plantas había dos métodos que a esa
edad me parecían increíbles el a codo
aéreo y los injertos en el primero
hacíamos unas fisuras en el tallo le
poníamos suelo hojarasca y un líquido
con ausín as estos reguladores de
crecimiento los más importantes para el
desarrollo de las plantas que aquí
tenían el papel de enraizar cortábamos
el tallo con raíces y teníamos una
planta idéntica a la planta madre pero
ya estoy de nuevo hablando de la ciencia
de las plantas y no estoy aquí para
hablar sobre ello
el otro era el injerto sorprendente
técnica de tomar una pequeña rama de una
planta de una especie similar a donde se
insertaba y esperar que creciera y
desarrollar y tener flores de otro color
o frutos de otro tipo
creo que asombroso verdad
la ciencia de las plantas
con esta emotiva historia si respondo la
segunda pregunta de cómo y cuándo nació
en mí el interés por la ciencia de las
plantas
nació con la enseñanza de mi familia
reforzando los conocimientos en la
escuela por los maestros
les comento otra vez
la experiencia exitosa del cultivo de
mis plantas no es sólo por ser
científico sino eso viene con la siembra
del conocimiento de cuando era niño
sembrar la semilla del conocimiento en
un niño ya sea en las aulas en la casa
con la familia hace nacer en él el
interés por cualquier área de la ciencia
hoy estoy aquí no para hablar sobre la
ciencia de las plantas sino para
dejarles esta experiencia de cómo saber
cultivar no solo plantas también ciencia
[Aplausos]